foreign
[Applause]
let's do it
the main best friend knows me
better than the therapist I pretend I go
to
[Laughter]
I why do why can guys just start
something
high pressure right away okay
and I I have to pee the second before
the second book is it a ritual or is it
I think it's because um
the way we pee right our bladders don't
totally empty because men invent toilets
well I don't know if that's the reason
men invented toilets did they cancel
toilets you heard it here first I'm a
fan of toilets because well I don't like
I'm not someone who goes like in the
woods or I don't like any of that I need
like I like to go to work because you
grew up in Connecticut Lyme disease I'm
scared of ticks on my dick at all times
but like toilet you're supposed to so
The Squatty Potty 101 thing
it's like you women don't completely
empty their bladders when they sit on a
toilet like all the pee doesn't totally
come out is this is this a real thing or
you're making this up they don't call me
ho Rogan for nothing so when women pee
all the P doesn't come out right away
because of the angle that we're peeing
with oh is it is it the uterus do you
guys have short uterus did you put
uterus in quotes and mispronounce it at
the same time no no not uterus the
uterus the uterus connect what's a uter
uterus
Jamie I'm gonna I'll start uterer uterer
uterine the bladder to the kidneys utero
uterer yeah Universe there are two of
them they connect and was this in a
Lenny brief install documentary that you
learned this no I learned this recently
you return uh what is it ureter ureter I
found this out yeah yes okay yes all
right exactly all right come on coming
in high here we go
you
the reader you read her okay so let's
just be clear about the
scientists and the men that named all
these things they were racist against
people with speech impediments okay
utero uterus think about like the guy
that was like
we just discovered this thing what do we
call it
a universe why because it's it's what
about like just a well I think it
probably comes from uretha right Pat
urethra urethra yeah I don't know
uretha it's a tube that travels from the
kidney and call it that yes the YouTube
no we couldn't call it that
that was 2000 years ago maybe why not
the YouTube yeah the YouTube that would
actually be great
the uterus you have an issue with you're
having UTIs because there's an issue
with your YouTubes no I'm having UTI
because I you know have sex with in
cells well that's we know that that's
not news
fit to print
um but like who cares okay but you know
20 years I always have to pee right
before I go on stage always
it must be it's nervous it's nervousness
you're not could you just pee at like
seven and then Dan you're on it's eight
and go no I always have to pee right
before two and then sometimes I do
sometimes and also go Jeremy hotz the
comedian always had that very funny joke
where he goes on stage his first line is
I have to pee I didn't plan this right I
love that joke so Jeremy haunts like I'm
probably gonna tell the story wrong
shucker but like you know what he did
with his hand is the comedian
who like do it he would just be like he
would do a punch line and then he would
go
and like kind of like with his hand and
it wasn't
it was just like the the very
you know like empty
hilarious like
sort of not not a tick but yeah it was
like his act he was like nervous guy
whatever was at work yeah but it wasn't
necessarily totally who he was in real
life not that it doesn't
not that it matters Jeremy hotz hotz and
there's a clip of him on um
Jay Leno's show when Jay was posting The
Tonight Show
and he was talking about um I think the
there was a he saw a sign that said lost
Bird yeah
yeah lost bird a lost bird it's like I
think he flew away something like that
something like that I don't know and
then he was doing butchering the jokes
but he's funny he was doing The Tonight
Show yeah sorry Jeremy
um he's putting loading a gun literally
Jeremy is low putting a bullet in his
gun
because we're destroying his jokes and
um uh do not let your toddlers go to
school today you guys
this week don't put them in school
because we're ruining his jokes
um
and he was doing the thing with his hand
or his finger and Jay Leno goes um uh
what's with the hand like after the set
what's with the hand and Jeremy just
goes it's an act Jay
I love that I love it when like
comedians
call
out other comedians that's so funny in a
way that only comedians understand on
the biggest platform in the world
it's an act Jay like everyone in the
audience was like what's act I read the
audience is just like what's happening
and it was just like that was like a
a resentment from like 30 years ago of
their friendship yeah
like on public television yeah that's so
good oh my god
um Dan levy my best friend I'm here
finally got your water finally got me
water
um I got water I have lukewarm coffee
it's all happening I if you I
look Postmates we are redistributing the
wealth it's fine well she didn't say do
you want coffee I said yeah sure I'll
get coffee and then she goes oh my
assistant's not working today did you
copy and paste this Dan I mean Dan's
order my order's great I asked Dan for
his order uh I said hey uh coffee
question mark it was rhetorical
I mean it wasn't it wasn't I have a
coffee maker ornie Adams knows how to
use it he's the only person I know that
has figured it out but I went coffee
question mark that doesn't mean can I
get it for you cop it's coffee but it it
kind of means do you want coffee when
you get here but also help me because
you've watched me evolve as a boss I
didn't think that you're you're not
someone who gets coffee but I thought oh
maybe it's the Christmas I don't know
she's out and about she wants to get
coffee please what do you know about
Christmas so I was like sure I'll get a
Grande Pike with a shot of espresso and
light half and half but my chief of
staff yes I don't say assistant I don't
like that okay because assistant when
people say my assistant I'm like it's
not your assistant yeah yeah you're an
assistant implies yes they're assisting
you in doing things you're doing right
no they're doing everything you could do
so you could do your own thing my
assistant does things I am not capable
of executing I know in anything I've
seen her work I've seen her like three
laptops at a time just like it's like
minority reports she's just like moving
shit around constantly lawyers
constantly calling foreign
elephants um okay so how do we FedEx an
elephant yeah she's on it so it's like
um I say Chief of Staff only problem
with that is what
Chief can we say Chief you can't say
Chief can we can't we you could say just
um president of a president of of Team
Whitney how about paid friend paid
friend paid friend
paid friend who I don't feel bad calling
at all hours of the night I'm super do
you but do you have by the way she also
used to run Caitlyn Jenner's um life
like she was Caitlyn Jenner's estate
um manager and I'm like this is
literally the same job the same job same
job same job same person same products
same doctors same everything
you're hired you're hired I need to
bring me over some of her pants I need
Caitlyn Jenner's guy yeah Katie oh my
God that's so funny so she so she that's
she's an angel of all Angels that's why
she seems so calm I feel like before
that that was just like yeah I ran over
more people you know like whatever like
the job interviews now like hiring I'm
so gnarly I finally figured out how to
hire people okay okay what is your
system you ready yeah the questions you
ask when you hire someone what are yours
um do you like Green Day
if not that is don't come here no we'll
have a Blink 182 okay come on aboard
what was it in the roast damn was on the
only fans roast of me which we're gonna
get to in a second but the only fan
throws to me Blink 182 is Dan's favorite
band and uh Jim Norton's number one
Tourette's symptom yeah yeah what what
Jim Norton always does
[Laughter]
I do love blink 182.
um so I was born into oh that's not true
blink
yeah I was born in 1982. oh yeah right
sorry sorry your only person no unless I
don't lie about my age I was thinking of
me I'm 81 you're 82. you're older than
me I know what's your daughter well I'm
not gonna say her name on you whatever
the fuck squibby uh uh Roku goes um uh
her your daughter was like how old are
you know it's like 40 and she goes my
dad's older than you and I was like
literally could like kill me my life my
life is complete she's obsessed with
ages your daughter yeah yeah
yep
go about so hiring hiring people I think
ice I I ask them
um you know are they are are they
available
to be like like they're obviously you're
not gonna work on the weekends but are
you sort of like okay with going with
the flow of sort of like you're not okay
with someone lying to you no every guy
every girl you've ever hit on has a
boyfriend
that's not true Every Girl's available
if it's enough no but I want to know
like are you are you are you available
um and are you okay with sort of like a
go with the flow schedule and not
necessarily sort of like you might not
really you're high okay so um on
basically a day-to-day situation are you
okay with not necessarily having like a
nine to six are you okay knowing do you
want me to answer or you're just gonna
keep yeah I'm gonna keep talking so what
was the question well now you're not
listening I heard I'm not hiring no I
listened that was the problem I would
okay if I'm if you're coming aboard sure
Dan Levi Enterprises my question to you
is
um are you okay with not having a full
like nine to five schedule
um obviously paid nine to five but are
you okay just sort of being sort of
needing to be available within those
hours as opposed to sort of having a
direct thing to do every
day are you okay with the fact that I'm
poor and I will say anything I need to
say to get this job sure hired
I don't like I will say I don't like
interviewing a lot of people so
sometimes I'll just like if I'm
interviewing like four people the fourth
person's great I'll be like you know
what let's do it my wife just said I
can't I don't know I probably this is
this is illegal to say my wife just said
I can't hire men male assistants because
she she feels like they are as capable
at doing life that I am and especially
if they're younger they have even less
experience so she was like I don't think
that you me personally for my needs
should hire a male assistant well Kevin
Spacey already hired all of them so
they're not available they're not
available not available
um so I have made a lot of hiring
mistakes I used to treat hiring people
like um dating or or finding a new
friend right at a bar you know yeah the
I think that our brain wiring is so
locked for the most part
these are the questions I ask Dan
pleasure to meet you nice to meet you
pleasure I I already know everything I
need to know based on how we schedule
the meeting right so that's a whole
other conversation okay uh where are you
from Dan I'm from Connecticut great cool
uh
where in Connecticut Stanford okay so
obviously say the city and the state
okay well I'm not applying for your job
right
I know Dan's never applied for dumb I
was just give it to you it's true give
it to you overpaid no questions asked
everyone around kind of annoyed that's
the dynamic this is by the way the only
thing we've never done is have a job
interview together yeah because Dan I
will not do a job unless Dan is there
and I'm there it's always fun yes
there's always people who are who are
are you Seinfeld or Larry David who's
who in this situation I think we're both
a mixture you're Larry Seinfeld I'm
Larry Seinfeld that is who I am so I'm
Elaine you're from um
I'm from Stamford Connecticut okay cool
did you um go to high school there yeah
I went to Stanford high school and then
I went to college no Sports no Sports
okay it has been a pleasure meeting you
so you like athletes I like well we'll
get to that team sports is a plus
someone that has played team sports yeah
I wish I played more team sports me too
yeah I wish you did yeah I wish you had
okay so someone that played team sports
you already know this person knows how
to share this person knows how to let
other people shine this person knows how
to like
dissolve their own ego for the benefit
of the greater good right right not to
work with other people communicate and
not take things personally right because
like volleyball basketball it's like do
it run shoot it like you can have those
emotions and then no one takes it
personally later right you know what I'm
saying yeah for me I like just did
improv so I don't have that athletic
backbone we saw the photo that you
xeroxed of you doing improv that is
right it made Howie Mandel sign in
Connecticut if people don't know this
story
um when I was 15 I went to go see how
Mandel perform at the Palace Theater in
Stanford Connecticut his closer was a
joke about adult adult diapers and the
punch line I meant to say assume the
punch line was him saying well it
depends and then the curtain dropped in
front of him was incredible I loved it
after the show I went up to him because
I knew people I got connections and I
went and I met him and I said Howie nice
to meet you my name is Dan Levy
um I just want to say I'm a huge fan can
you sign this and I think as most people
would assume it was like a poster or a
DVD or Bobby's World thing and it was
just a Xerox copy of me doing improv and
I asked how Mandel to sign it and he did
and I also sight unseen yeah there's
certain things that people do when
they're younger that are uh is it a red
herring or a Harbinger what is it when
you like like
you're a star like how does someone know
your star so you know a child is going
to be a psychopath if they kill a cat
like 10. yeah yeah like I would have
known that you were gonna be a star in
that moment at 15. you know how like if
if a kid puts throws a cat on a fire you
go oh that's going to be a serial killer
murderer yeah yeah my Xerox copy of me
doing improv to Howie is like this guy's
gonna make it a show business like 100
this guy's so delusional that's so
delusionally confident and has such a
strong work ethic like went to Kinkos
like I mean this was like to Xerox a
photo back then also in Stanford around
the same time that Michael Bolton you
know amazing singer sure who's by the
way Netflix special I passed on one of
my great one of my great career highs
Michael Bolton is doing a Valentine's
Day special and you say no and I pass
you're crazy you'd be living with him in
Westport right now I'm good so my
Michael Bolton did a charity softball
game in Connecticut and I went to
Charities
and scams just really quick Charities
rich people they get to get write-offs
on their taxes no charities or most
Charities are a complete fucking fraud
phony scam keep going charity softball
okay so Rob Schneider's there and I'm
obviously Elle King is his daughter I
know but at the time incredible singer
at the time I don't even know if she was
born yet I was so excited to see him
love Rob Schneider from SNL so he's
playing Left Field okay and I am just on
the bench waiting you know in
the crowd and I started yelling to him I
like the juice because he did that in
SNL like there's a baseball game going
on like I like it the juice I like it
the Jews screaming damn and he like
looks over and I think he actually is
kind of excited because someone is like
a a fan of that and then he walks over
and he goes the juice is good I was like
yeah I like the juice and then I had him
sign
um a dry cleaning ticket because again I
didn't I wasn't prepared okay how were
you I think I was 15. 14 year old goes
to a dry cleaner how rich did you grow
up no I didn't grow up rich I needed
something to sign well how did you get a
dry cleaning time
someone give me something to sign and I
walk over to him and I still have it
somewhere it says to the Dan Meister
love Rob Schneider and uh I haven't seen
him since but you know what God bless
him for being the fact that back then he
was like oh God I'm gonna sign this
thing for this kid what a waste of time
I'm famous that now us talking about it
here is the most relevant he's been oh
no not kidding you know what I mean yeah
but like those little Easter egg magic
moments I think are fascinating it's
like if because like especially with
comedy like I was talking about this
with um Rodney Dangerfield's widow
um Howie Mandel and maybe
who Joan Rivers uh daughter Melissa
river is like because comedy's so young
it's 100 years old in America right
right like you can we can talk about
like Court jesters and the role of the
Joker in um Batman
which Tim Dylan is in by the way amazing
um which I look like without makeup you
are the Joker I am the poster
Todd Phillips how did you not cast how
did Todd Whitney as the Joker Todd
Phillips we we need to talk Todd
Phillips the fact that you have not
hired me my face yeah just my face just
her face my robot just actually your
face who played and the outfits that you
wear I mean you are the Joker hey Todd
Phillips why do you hate money Todd
Phillips do you want to get richer look
you have the Joker right here you want
to buy Epstein island or not come on
look at this joke you could add that
shit to cart in a heartbeat huge I'm
telling you who even played oh Joaquin
Phoenix come on whatever love Joaquin
Phoenix out here uh one thing about
Joaquin Phoenix we used to go to the
same trainer Ben Bruno who love you
genius he's like he's like a real deal
trainer in La most of them are just like
hack like weirdos creeps um that want
reality shows by the way half the
trainers that I used to overpay to like
tell me to run around the block have
like Netflix reality shows now
everyone everyone like produced by Matt
Damon like what's happening I know
everyone is why are my former trainers
more successful than me I have questions
everyone is doing everything okay okay
why is that guy I went to get a massage
from
10 years ago on CW yeah because Rachel
Bilson gave me a gift card and now it's
awesome seven episodes order
on Hulu
um but Hollywood baby
um help me who you're talking about you
being the Joker and being mad that Todd
Phillips hasn't cast you but I'm not
sure I'm actually not sure
you talking to Melissa oh we're the
first generation of comedians okay so
we're the first generation that can
comment on Legends right within the
Hundred Years of of comedy in America
right so it started uh chitlin circuit
Vaudeville May West Moms Mabley but like
it it's now is the first time ever that
comedians that actually have earned the
right to comment on Legends yeah like
we're the second generation of Comedy
famous comedy comedy yeah basically
which is a lot it's kind of wild yeah
it's weird that it's not that that has
not been that long yeah is that crazy
that is crazy there is a uh documentary
on Amazon that is truly awful I mean it
is it is the way it's so good it is
awful it is about the Catskills okay it
is uh is about
um how uh because I'm doing all this
research because we're doing the Phyllis
Diller uh miniseries history of Comedy I
don't know what I can say and when I
can't but I have final cut this is my
show we can cut it off whatever why am I
panicking
um who cares Lauren Michael's pay people
more
um but uh
that
um Catskills Jew because comedy very
much was like an immigrant coping
mechanism yes right yeah and uh Jewish
people hot take Kanye I know you're our
number one subscriber Kanye half Jewish
here we go let's have Jewish I'm 180
Jewish
and um
It's A coping mechanism but a lot my
brain today is so fucking wild I just
tried to get on to book an Airbnb and
I'm so fucking pissed off
because just real quick sidebar if you
book an Airbnb if you have a new account
they think you're fishy right but I've
been booking it under my chief of
staff's name I've been on Airbnb for 10
years all over the country getting stuff
yeah six years and then now I it's her
day off back to Kate my your sister
staff yeah is today a holiday or not
it's the Monday after Christmas it's not
a holiday
so she should be working I mean it
depends when you're giving her a week
off for Christmas I don't know
I don't feel comfortable letting her
work today okay because she doesn't feel
comfortable not working well then she's
got to work because I feel like last
week is the vacation and this should I
send her a puzzle
[Music]
it feels like this is not the vacation's
over right I don't know I feel like last
week is a vacation and now it's Monday
and now it's new New Year's is coming up
whoa I'm snapping is your Chief of Staff
needs to get here so I don't have to
have a lukewarm cup of joe so
um so yeah I just I don't know I just I
want yeah it also blows my mind that
people want to work right like they if
they like their boss they want to work
yeah she has a job that she doesn't hate
and I think that I'm so conditioned to
be like most people are like
um working to build someone else's dream
and they're being like abused and
they're in this fucked up holding
pattern but she's not and I have to like
remind myself of that yeah she seems
great yeah like the other day uh two
days ago I delivered her Christmas uh
gift to her whatever holiday gift
Christmas gift call HR I don't give a
fuck you know what I mean you know what
the fuck I mean how fucking dare you no
one's saying the fact that I got a call
from HR when I was working on Roseanne
for saying Merry Christmas to the
interns that's not true fuck that's not
true 100
you got called from HR I was leaving
well this was actually after
we were doing an episode of um about Dan
if you've seen Roseanne hot scoop this
is hot guys uh Roseanne uh Dan from
Roseanne he was a contractor independent
contractor outside rural Illinois yes
right
and uh cut to whatever 20 years later
okay Roseanne now
the show not the person the show Dan
would be 65 independent contractor
um what would his biggest problem be
that undocumented workers were competing
with him for his business right for like
yeah handy uh the construction so he
comes in and he says the illegals are
did a cheaper bid
and we didn't get the job
okay okay
he would say illegals
right yeah because that's what his
character would say humans can't be
illegal obviously right but in the
privacy of someone's own a 65 year old
man from rural Illinois's own home in
his kitchen with his wife he'd say
illegals yeah and probably something
worse
to be illegals is actually
pretty woke in terms of what the people
of the Midwest might be saying behind
closed doors but I understand it's 2022
or 2021 whenever the function 100 yeah
so then I get this call that's like you
know they're upset that Dan's saying
legals after the run-through right I
haven't said run through in so long run
through is what we do when we like
practice the TV show before we shoot it
exactly and everyone's upset that Dan's
sang illegals you should say
undocumented workers Dan wouldn't even
fucking know what that meant the
character no wouldn't even know wouldn't
care
plus I feel like at that point now you
have to tell the actor that you are now
rewriting stuff and he doesn't have time
to memorize no world am I gonna walk up
to John Goodman yeah the great Legend of
John Goodman and go hey we need to do an
I I know that
um you're a legend and all
I know you're like God's gift to acting
um and you've put up with this nightmare
energy for 40 years
and have been bound in a prison
of ancestral women's nonsense
um can we do one more take where you
just say undocumented workers instead of
illegals for for habit this for
absolutely no reason at all
except to appease the ego of some uh
girl that went to Vassar
whose dad works at Vogue
like what what's happening I remember
when we worked on the whitneys that come
I got a call from HR because I was like
doing these pranks where you would you
would basically do a coffee run you know
where people would hand out you know you
had a clipboard a clip art a clipboard a
clip
yeah a clipboard you're aligning uterine
uh and you would write down your name
and your coffee order and that was what
it was and you would rotate who'd paid
for it okay so okay so in a writer's
room yes there was a clipboard piece of
paper we're ordering coffee every day
yes to give Starbucks more money because
they are an independent struggling
mom-owned business I will be the face of
your company though
and um I should be the mermaid I should
be the Starbucks Mermaid that's Todd
Phillips thank you
the Starbucks Mermaid movie starring The
Joker merman merman yes um I love merman
so I me as the Starbucks Mermaid gave me
all the money I'll redistribute the
wealth reparations
please handle call Katie yeah call Katie
um so everyone writes down their order
right so as a funny bit what I would do
is I would because it was always
rotating someone's like credit card so
when it was Adrian's turn one of our
writers I love Adrian it's so funny
um I wrote down 100 gift card
right
for first credit card that's that this
is almost like when Okay so
uh uh clowns be clowning and we can't
see comedians we don't take time off
okay we're always goofing okay always
trying to make each other laugh nine to
five five if that's not for you
you're a fucking nerd and a dork and
just go go buy another fucking
protractor and pocket protector go back
to Staples where you belong yeah but
like this is like when I used to go to
auditions when I was not successful at
all had no seven dollars was eating uh
uh shoplifted turkey jerky from pink
dots with maple syrup I would go into
auditions for TV shows like Law and
Order Two and a Half Men whatever the
fuck
two and a half man me and Caitlyn
Jenner's new sitcom and uh
I would write on the sign-in sheet you
have to write your name yes and your
agency
and regard I would always write
Don
buckwald's associate dumb Buck Walt
Associates one of his associates even
even if I was not represented by that
it's just so funny because I wanted the
because I knew if it was I I got called
in for funny roles I knew other Comics
would come in yeah and see it for the
part and see it and make them laugh so I
was literally ruining my own career in
confusing casting directors to hope that
someone else would come in as a comic
and CNN try and make Angela Johnson
laugh in three hours if she even made it
what was that one show that was with
what's her face from Dharma and Greg
that was uh
it was it was about her having a baby
with a younger guy it was called like
pizza party no it was called like kids
time or like Darwin Greg no no was she
was from Dharma Greg but it was called
like user sitcom this is like a silly
silly Liza or something probably props
silly Liza anyways my point is silly
line Pat did you find out what it's
called Pat Uh Jenna Elfman sitcom
um accidentally on purpose that's what
it was called and I know this because it
reminded me of it dude because I
auditioned accidentally on purpose
brought to you by Texas uh uterine
lining legislation I okay I auditioned
for actually on purpose weekly never got
cast every week I'd go and I sign my
name like this is it actually on purpose
they're bringing me in sorry never cast
anyways so back to the writer's room I
wrote down 100 gift card and thermos as
a joke as a joke so it's like so when I
so if someone buys me so it's like if
you and I are on a date right and I'm in
my 20s and 30s and we go get coffee and
it's like oh I'm about to I'm buying
some stuff and you're like oh no I got
it and I'm like okay we're on a date
right coffee about to check out I'm
gonna get a coffee
um I'll got it oh oh that oh can I also
get a 100 gift card
like that's it yeah that's what we did
that would be what is so anyways but
that so then the coffee orders come and
everyone gets their coffee when he gets
her green tea latte which
green tea that takes what she loves and
we would every other coffees and then
they hand Adrian a hundred dollar gift
card and a thermos
it's so funny oh and then um and then
but then HR called me and they go hey we
have a complaint from you and I was like
did Adrian complain they're like no one
of the Pas felt like it was offensive
that I was using them to help
um create bits and I was like oh my God
they should put it on your resume on
your life don't look great put it on
your resume you fucking dork you should
be so lucky and I was like what and
they're like yeah they just don't want
you to like you know have them go and
buy thermoses and gift cards as jokes
and I was like oh my God okay I guess
I'll stop I'm so sorry you have the most
fun job ever yeah you should be I would
be so stoked if I was like 22 when I
went to Starbucks and I got to buy it
can I tell you I'm I'm not raised I I
Really Work to not be racist homophobic
because I am ageist against some young
people if you were 22 and you think you
have a good idea walking to HR
snort cocaine laced with fentanyl I
promise you that's the best option for
you like shut your mouth and just learn
I am but I'm impressed I mean the 20
year olds today like they are so hot so
uh no no sexy no tight pussy
um titled
but it's not even entitled I think it's
just more like like um do I sound too
old saying that the word entitled I
think just has gotten muddy because it's
like I think that social media Twitter I
think that that there's a lot of wisdom
in Youth and there's a lot of there's
wisdom that only comes with age and I
think that you just have to know the
difference I think it's yes
there's a difference between knowledge
and wisdom but I think if you bring it
into show business it's such a weird PL
it's a it's a different business than
the other businesses you might enter so
when you are young and entitled or
whatever you want to say I think
sometimes it's a little bit like okay
okay well I get that you have this sort
of like aggressive like thing that you
feel like you want to make things happen
and I I God bless you I think you should
but it's not just gonna happen you still
have to like work towards yeah but it's
about your motive it's like are you here
to or for a job to snitch or are you
here to learn right so just listen when
you go to work and if you're working
around people that have something you
want just listen learn observe if you
see something you don't like this is
what I did it worked sorry
um uh I saw the stuff that I didn't like
and I just went when I'm in charge I'm
not going to do that yes when I'm in
charge I'm not going to do that I just
learned instead of snitching because
every time you snitch to HR it goes on
your record forever right so when I want
to hire someone I'll go oh he worked at
all these places she works at all these
places great oh they filed a complaint
about
a coffee order 10 years ago
I don't know about this guy this guy
seems like uh he really just like he
seems like he wants attention this this
person seems like he is lonely this
person seems like he has a crushed guy
didn't think buying a thermos was funny
this guy see has a crush on the HR
person looks like you need an excuse to
go to the HR office like you know what
I'm saying it just doesn't track right
but for inner job interviews I'm going
Sports what sports did you play tell me
all about it I want to know okay
um siblings siblings interesting and you
know how many siblings in birth order
if you're an only child
bye
your roles here are limited
if you had a
sibling and it perished you're promoted
right if you're an orphan welcome
welcome foster child all day long yeah
so like I need to know your birth order
and siblings okay because that's like it
just it has a indelible impact on the
way your brain is wired sharing
negotiating right like being able to
um uh tolerate adversity discomfort that
kind of thing so what is your perfect
employee like a like a division a
division one athlete who comes from like
thank God I just got out of Russia like
who we just released her like Greg Brady
is that who is your perfect I don't like
employing people it's my name I like to
I want to do everything myself ideally
yeah because I don't like I don't like a
hierarchy with other people and like and
my main the Only Rule I have is we don't
say you work for me you work with me
right we're a team we're a wolf pack and
we go do it yeah and it's like and we're
all one team and so far this new this
new Chief of Staff has been great
because have you you must have learned
you must have learned from all your
other well because I always wanted to
and it worked it did exactly what I need
to do when it was done I always wanted
to I hate the word Mentor it's so
fucking um uh self-aggrandizing I always
wanted to hire people that I could uh I
hate the word help too
um help basically you know so like Megan
uh first assistant Megan Hearn it was
like I wanna I like to hire people that
I will work for one day right I'm
training you to replace me yes because
I'm tired Megan was great the best she
was has jewelry jewelry company that
does uh uh uh Liza Hooper yeah directs
movies whatever so I go what I used to
do is I Hoops the first thing I would
ask is like what do you want to do for a
living what do you want the only thing
they did wrong was there was one time I
bought Book of Mormon tickets through
your StubHub do you remember this and it
never got changed and to this day if I
log on StubHub it's like Whitney
Cummings you're going to dear Evan
Hansen I'm like get this username off my
StubHub
forever forever you get me I think I
gave those tickets to June refill really
and then she couldn't go okay well
you're welcome I need to I need to
I need to confront her about that okay I
forgot about that I forgot that's a
thorn in my side that I forgot about
okay it's okay it's all right it's more
than like nine hundred dollars they were
they were good tickets
they were good tickets yeah can I say
something that is gonna be a real a real
bombshell what I've never seen Book of
Mormon ah you gotta go it's it's so
funny Book of Mormon there are certain
things I don't know this happens to you
there's certain things in my life that I
go to you know as an audience member and
I in the middle of it I will have these
moments of being like I don't think I'm
good enough to be in entertainment yeah
and I feel like that happens but the
people that think like that are the ones
that are qualified but that's how I felt
like when I saw a book of Mormon that's
how I felt like when I saw the person
Ali G movie you know like all all that
kind of stuff I'm like oh my God I was
like I'm Book of Mormon I'm you're
laughing and you're so and you just
can't believe what you're seeing yeah I
mean this is an uh it's an old take I
think but it's more like but it's great
yeah it's when you see like oh someone
put eight years into this yes you know
what I mean yeah yeah and like well
deserved I love it and do you like
musicals though but I think that the
kind of people that do that
um lin-manuel uh the the all the guy
Book of Mormon like
during the seven years they were working
on Hamilton they weren't going to see
other Hamiltons they weren't going to
see the other things that took seven
years because they were so busy working
on that thing you know what I mean yeah
I don't want to get discouraged
right you know but there are as
entertainers there are very few things
that make us feel like we are
a fan yes you know what I mean yeah yeah
and that and that's one for you like I'm
fascinated by who entertains the
entertainers yeah like where what what
can we go sit down and just totally get
lost and not think about work well
that's why the greatest Community ever
was Brodie Stevens because I feel like
everyone felt that way about him comics
comics could watch Brody Stevens and
feel like a fan in Tampa watching Nate
bargatzi or whatever it is you know what
I mean like that like I'm not
competitive I'm not feeling like I could
have done it better I'm not feeling bad
about myself I could never think like
that I would never like I don't I didn't
audition for this like watching movies
TV shows for us it's just like why did
they cut there why did they do that is
this Union where do they shoot this like
that oh God that PA got fucked on that
shot like I feel bad it makes me feel
bad because it's like you know like my
main sort of like goal in terms of like
Hollywood baby hold on I haven't done
this it's it's
Hollywood baby so
um
I'm all about the next like thing for me
is like Humane Hollywood like how do you
make a production humanely because I'm
not going to do any I I'm like very
suspicious in trepidations about
Hollywood right now because I'm like
it's not about what you're making it's
about how you're making it but you just
did a production we were part of it and
it was good totally and no humans were
harmed in the making of the only fans
Rose of witty Cummings except for you
except for me except for you emotionally
but harm but that's like the only way I
can come yeah Jeremy so you loved it it
was a great great day yeah so I want to
get to the only fans roast of Whitney
Cummings just really quick just I'll
just where are your parents from uh
ancestors from uh that's what I ask in
job interviews do you play sports are
you only child what's the birth order
ancestry and it's not about like not
giving them a job because of it because
those are all things that people can't
control it's about figuring out where
they fit yes and and why you do do 23 of
me them I make them spit into it
oh okay well I'm gonna need you to hawk
a loogie in his wrote that please um I
really I just I need some diversity in
my in my life I just I just take some
blood
I need to know your two percent
um from Tanzania that will help me a lot
um dude the only fans roast of Whitney
company like what is your take how did
you feel like it was from the moment I
asked you
when you first asked me I was like oh my
God like what is this gonna be like is
it gonna you know because you're you you
are the in charge of it but you're also
The Roaster so I was like I don't want
to roasting roasty you're the roastee so
when I first signed on to do it I was
like okay but I need to make sure
there's jokes I'm gonna say that Whitney
doesn't know we're coming because I
that's the whole show there's a whole
part of the most fun about the roast is
being like surprising surprisingly so
that was the that was the only hard part
because you were in The Writer's room
you know and then it is weird to roast a
person oh dude this is like Dan O'Brien
on um the uh when we did the Whitney
sitcom Dan O'Brien the most brilliant
actor like we were watching back because
some that I'm hanging out with we like
watch the Whitney sitcom we like took
mushrooms and like he had never seen it
said I'm dating I love that the first
thing you do with your new boyfriend is
you haven't watched the Whitney sitcom
also but that wasn't the first I know I
know first I had him watch My Demo real
yes okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna watch My Demo they're gonna
watch Whitney I'm gonna have you watch
that watch the female version of David
Hasselhoff okay no but I did if you're
gonna date me in any capacity there are
certain movies you have to have seen not
mine or whatever Truman Show like
there's certain Truman Show Windy City
Heat Labyrinth there's certain movies
like references I make so much the
comeback right well I will say I'm
making fun of you but the first time I
when I met my wife and we were dating
like for like a few weeks she was going
to Florida to visit her parents and she
didn't see him perform yet so I gave her
a DVD of my stand-up
a DVD of me performing like I would
rather have an STD at that point
can I get an STD from you and I was like
enjoy your flight but it worked because
now we're married we have 100 and she
used it to cut herself yeah on the
JetBlue flight
um but so so I do think that like when
we date like so much confusion happens
because we have such different
hippocampus like data sets set points so
it's like and we all talking is such an
imperfect way to communicate I like
going like here's like the five movies
in the five TV shows to watch talking
with you is definitely an imperfect
talking with you is definitely not the
perfect way to communicate
I'm a millionaire but
um so and then like here are the three
podcasts like to understand who I am
because we spend so much time going like
well you know it's like like we spent so
much time explaining the shortcut of
using like metaphors and allegory of
like it's like the the um Ludo from
Labyrinth yes and then someone's like
what's that and you're like
like we would be in love right now if
you just knew that reference everything
would make so you kind of give whoever
you're dating like all your stuff like
this is all the stuff to watch it's not
like homework like in summer I call it
summer reading but like really if you if
you want to understand me yeah this is
the way to do it like this is a way to
cut two years of us like fighting and me
explaining stuff to you and perfectly
because when you explain stuff to people
it's like patronizing to them does that
work and that's why I masculate
but I'm like well there's a movie called
Labyrinth and David Bowie is this guy
and then he said how have you not
fucking say this and then I'm like I
need to call your parents because they
abuse you how have you not seen this so
that's I feel like we have to just like
gently be like
get out of my house and come back for
your rock climbing wall
the shape of water is a big one like
there's just certain and then I go like
what are your favorite shows and then
I'll watch those and then it'll help me
understand so the the new guy you're
dating now what are the shows that he's
into
um well I need to watch for him okay so
my big thing on uh the person I'm going
to be with forever is saving my
virginity in other ways okay okay so my
my vaginal virginity that ship sailed
right literally I had my virginity taken
on a ship
on a cruise in the Virgin Islands that's
not a joke that's not a joke swear to
God a guy from Schenectady New York oh
wow you met him you met him on the
cruise correct wow okay Virgin Islands
which by the way
what's this which by the way Yachts
we'll get to this later when we write
this down Yachts wait Yachts are the
Disney cruise
Yachts are only to do illegal things on
right did you know that I this just
dawned on me like I didn't know I don't
know I don't know billionaires have
Yachts why so you go deep in the water
why
why I don't know I don't I don't love
it's not like there's no international
law on Waters there's no law oh you can
do anything why are all these
billionaires Park their Yachts like 7
000 yards I'm not great with distance
metric shit from Italy
right why are they parked out in the
water there's a there's tons of great
hotels that's why there's been so many
Pirates
you lost me
Edwards Don't Pirates are Lawless it all
makes sense great and we're back we're
back so why they go on Yachts the only
reason to have a yacht is fear of crime
underage girls to go on the yacht were
you underage when when with this guy
from Schenectady New York
obviously but I don't think he was over
age okay okay I didn't ask okay I didn't
care what is happening but I'm just
saying that was a cruise that's
different Carnival you're cool but
except for that coven thing yeah yeah
but and the crash and the polluting the
oceans but whatever
um
that's what Yachts are for that's what
yeah Yachts are for fucking underage
people doing illegal things okay there's
no law enforcement on Yachts but there
is there's the why wouldn't you just
stay in a hotel but what about the
patrol the what what are they called the
there there's cops in the water
stingrays no there there's a term it's
uh they're Mall Cop they're no they're
they're boat cops
what are they called Pat
Coast Guard a coast guard Coast Guard or
boat tops and they are out there taking
down the guys on the yacht no no those
guys only job is to fish out like
married men's wives that got a life
insurance policy that want to move on
with some bitch and plenty of fish that
that that is that that is they're really
only made for 2020. why is a billionaire
have a yacht
uh what's a football field Pat how many
are is that 100 years 100 yards
so 200 yards away yeah from Positano
Italy is like 10 billionaire yacht
stocked out there
why and then you're you're claiming that
it's because they are all why not stay
at the hotel I don't know I want to rent
a house why not buy a house you have a
billion dollars why are you floating on
the water instead that's a good question
I don't know I'm not a boat guy I get
seasick immediately so I would be in a
very nice way why is any human ever in
the ocean
it is makes no sense it's fishy what
about you thank you we're not designed
to be honest with you thank you
we're not designed to be on it by the
way shout out Ricky Velez his HBO
special the drug dealer in the ocean
yeah genius you can deal drugs you can
do drugs you can have a fuck you can
have younger age people on a yacht and
once you're in the water it's fine L Ron
Hubbard Scientology he did why do you
think Scientology has Yachts I I don't
know if they do they do they're
Scientology Yachts yes wow most of their
crimes you know a lot about the yacht
it's a sea org this is the sea org this
is the most I've ever talked or heard
about Yachts you need to you need to do
like an NPR episode Yachts are a problem
this is your cereal
its Yachts are where all the shit goes
down dude international waters so
Scientology they can commit all their
crimes on water because no one can
enforce laws on there except for the the
patrol
the Coast Guard Coast Guard the Coast
Guard needs to step it up I'm sure let's
I want to know who pays for the Coast
Guard the Coast Guard feels like a
convenient distraction by the pedophiles
on the Yachts okay you're on YouTube too
much you're on too much YouTube change
the subject to be you're on too much to
be no but I just Yachts are like I just
I got my eye on you I just want people I
want Yachts the yacht Community just so
you guys know Whitney's looking at what
is it what is the point of yacht I mean
I think the point of the audience what's
the point of anything just to kind of
feel important but if you're a
billionaire why are you on a yacht I
don't know I would not go on the yard
because you can do illegal shit on Water
I know you keep saying you can't do on
land that's true but certain certain
right why would you want to have no
Wi-Fi
why would you want to have no cell
service why would you want to be in the
middle of the fucking ocean
you gotta have Wi-Fi and Yachts probably
how else are you going to email galane
[Laughter]
um Todd Phillips she should also play
galane in this Joker I think so come on
no that's gonna be another one all that
goes to Aubry Plaza instead
it's good I mean it's like Aubry I love
Aubry Plaza I really do it's just like
it's like
I don't think I don't think my time as
an actor has come yet I think it's like
going to be like well you have this new
show coming out yeah the fox drama I
think it's gonna be like I think I was
born to play
a Villain Like a Villain evil
like white witch really don't you think
I don't know I think I still think one
of the funniest scripts that you ever
wrote was that the one where you were
just like driving around and uh Suzanne
Summers was was your neighbor and you
were like a struggling comic and it was
just like you and Neil Brennan in a car
I was like I'll watch this show that was
for Comedy Central yes
um uh Comedy Central who uh live at
Gotham 140 comic got it I did not
um drove to Bray improv no less than 16
times with hair extensions didn't get it
didn't get Montreal it was the hair
extensions did the John did the drone
look I stand with you I stand with
Ukraine
but my hair extensions are Russian so we
can't totally break our relationship
with Russia they've got half the world's
fertilizer and very good hair it makes
me wonder though because it's like
everyone's like the people in Russia are
oppressed but like they're the women are
eating well if their hair is your hair
looks good this is Russian hair Mazel
tough
you're Jewish so
um
help me so you were talking about the
fact that
what were we talking about you tell Pat
you're talking about how it's it's
difficult to be in the writer's room
when the roast is about you oh that was
like two hours ago
no
grounding okay
we're in trouble are we not paying
attention walk through the valley with
the shadow one down Michelle Pfeiffer in
Dangerous Minds over here wow oh my God
this is the greatest pot ever but it's
true always you might not think so wait
because we might not be listening to
each other by the way uh Molly uh
writer's assistant on um uh the rose
rose um texture I just text her this
super inspiring thing she wrote me
yesterday like this has been one of the
most incredible experiences of My Life
um I will send you some thoughts soon
hoping for season two I want to do this
I wrote
um not imperative blah blah uh I wrote
you are a dream and I look forward to
being fired by you one day and then
we're having this like super like
um
look at us we're moving forward you're
gonna can I go can I get the link to
can I get the master doc of jokes about
me
after this long thing she writes that's
so funny I out of pod with Dan Levy I
think she's off this week
when is the next I mean
Chrysler we shot two we'll get to that
in a second so doing the rose for only
fans
um I think I've already explained why
I'm doing only fans number one I don't
want to do any more Hollywood
Productions that are distributed or made
in an inhumane way where like supply
chain I don't know shit about like you
know what I mean where people are
underpaid overworked there's all these
like
you know it's just the system of
Hollywood was made by men the hours the
budget the hiring process it was
designed by men who wanted to cheat on
their wives and that's fine but it's not
the way I'm gonna do business it's like
why on multicam sitcoms are we shooting
the TV show on Friday at 5 00 PM you
want to create a system where wives
could she and their husbands a 100 I
wanted criticism where wives don't get
married at our wives women don't have to
get married at all because who why are
we fucking getting the government
involved you know so it's like yeah so
it's like
okay so it's like so
I just feel like uh like remember like
on on the NBC show it was like five
o'clock on Friday when everyone is there
at their most tired they're most
exhausted we're shooting the most high
stakes thing everyone they can't see
their kids they can't pick their kids up
from school this just makes no sense why
don't we shoot the show Monday or block
shoot the pre-shooting Monday and
Tuesday so everyone has the weekend to
rest they come in fresh Monday morning
and they've had the actors of time to
learn their lines all the crew is rested
yeah you could I mean you you can
rearrange the schedule like we did my
shows on Tuesday nights for that reason
yes yes it's just none of it makes any
sense there's like all these there's too
many people doing too many jobs that are
underpaid instead of a couple people
that get paid more and have Humane hours
like the whole thing just doesn't make
any sense and if we were able to hire
more moms I'm not trying to be like a
feminist cunt tart or whatever you call
them like moms are just very good at
managing time like their brains change
when they're pregnant like you need
mom's on set dude when people are
freaking out and fighting they're like
you guys need water yeah all I do is
multitask all day long they just give
snacks out and it's handled they have
orange slices in their fucking pussy
it's like over so it's like in order to
get more moms on set which would make
more Humane hours and shit we just got
to do Child Care on set right by child
care I don't mean hiring some fucking
hobo out of the backs there are three
background checks on the babysitters
yeah the kids can't be like sitting by a
smoke machine
or in a fucking I mean that's the other
thing is they're like yeah we'll have
childcare instead there's a babysitter
on set and uh uh the the kid will be
right there next to the mom who's
directing the show it's like next to the
buzz saw next to the bus and the smoke
machine next next to the grip vaping and
the left and the lead paint yeah next to
the sexual predator that's the actor
okay let's this is not you know yeah so
it's like trying to actually figure it
out so it's like when we did the only
fans rows I don't want to blow some of
the surprises but on each show we had uh
Moms performing and they had child care
in the hotel across the street right you
know what I mean and it was just like
made everything yeah it was really one
way I was able to get them it was very
well organized there was a good a really
good support group of people that you
put together I feel like yeah it felt
funny and safe and it was great and it
was also like like I hate the word
patriarchy and matriarchy and all that
shit is so dumb but it's like when when
I don't even woman who cares when
someone is in charge that is just like
wants everyone to be taken care of like
you get better work everyone feels safe
and everyone can be braver yeah so it's
all I mean there was air one every day
every day every day which Whitney
Cummings versus arawan will be a lawsuit
for the ages because I did I did find
that there's a certain bread they sell
at Walmart that's four dollars that is
twelve dollars an air one oh it's one
bread but wow but count on this bitch to
fucking find the one because everything
else I also need another breakdown so
that's my other thing when you're buying
something I'm going okay it's fine if
this is twelve dollars these farm eggs I
just need to know that most of the
money's going to the motherfucker that
farm this shit right who wears the money
I'll pay the twelve dollars as long as
it's going to the pharmacy oh the money
is definitely going to like a house in
the Palisades okay yeah like is it going
to a Saudi like who's
where is Mr erwan I need instead of
ingredients on the back of food at this
point I need like a this is the
breakdown of where the money goes
I know is my money going to Clorox or
not like I just gotta know what's up so
have you followed the Erawan money yet
I'm on it I because I do love the food I
could be the great totally I could be
the face totally yeah
you're the face of everyone Hi I love
Japanese sweet potatoes and I love
salmon I'll pay 65 for that no problemo
I'm Dan so this is like arawan you guys
have seen it on Kendall Jenner's stories
it's like the it's like that and Whitney
comics
um coming out of it rapidly into a
toilet your favorite thing
um but uh uh everyone it's like a very
it's hard
it reveals the fact that in order to eat
healthy in America you have to be a
millionaire it's so fucked up you know
what I mean it's like the only way
people not the only way but it's like a
fast expensive way to get farm raised
organic healthy shit yeah I have to
start growing my own ship in the yard
you can every time I'm here they're
planting more trees I mean eventually
there's going to be yeah so we're
planting milkweed because milkweed the
monarchs are going extinct which is what
pollinates shit so we're planting
milkweed everywhere to get the monarchs
to come back okay yeah I mean so we got
the monarchs I don't know what you mean
but I'm yes handing you
improv skills
[Laughter]
so we're getting the monarchs back and
then I want to do growing their own
vegetables
but
key to Growing your own vegetables is
what Dan
you're gonna water this
we don't have any in California I know
that's what okay what's the key to
vegetables is fertilizer if you're
growing your own clothes if you're
growing your own vegetables
oh my God we haven't even gotten to the
roast jokes yet what if you're growing
your own vegetables in your vegetable
garden number one got to keep it
enclosed and make sure that the coyotes
and the rats and the everything have
their own food source on the other so
that they don't eat all your vegetables
right but you gotta menstruate in a cup
put it in the soil no
no vegetables in my house this is
Hollywood where no means yes is that
what I'm only growing eggplant is that
what everything's marinated with an
erwan is that what it is
oh my God they can't kill Hannah's uh
that can't be real so there's evidence
now that this is
because
I'll tell you what a second
if you put your menstrual blood in the
soil of vegetables the vegetables will
start producing the vitamins that you
lack based on the information they got
from your menstrual blood okay what's
the caveat on that everything I'm not
I'm ready to move on
me and Pat are ready to move on to the
next topic of the podcast which is Rose
jokes some of us don't fuck through a
sheet okay
um and but the thing the thing I get
hung up on on that is like but how do
you know that it's not from P because p
and menstrual blood they kind of mix
together yeah I just don't I don't know
where your who your farmer is but I'm
gonna tell you to look for someone new
his name is Alex Jones
yeah I'm gonna say I think it's time to
just find someone else lots of
landscaping in L.A
I have um my good friend Abby Cohen
she's incredibly talented hire her she
has not mentioned once about menstrual
blood in the plants you guys I have two
dead parents and enough money to all the
mushrooms in California
major major
she did Ayahuasca did mushrooms on a
live podcast we are shitting on a carrot
outside in Topanga
placenta we'll get to that another day
yeah another day okay so let's see if I
got the jokes okay so the roast of meat
so basically it's like I want to bring
back the roast edgy the only way to do
truly Fearless fucking brutal comedy is
to make the safest environment possible
because right now it was like men can't
do it guys can't do it they're too
scared right and like the tradition of
the roasts when it was on TV was I don't
want to say the word mean it was um
mercenary and like sloppy because it was
mixing Comedians and celebrities that's
like comedian that's like mixing um
heavyweight MMA fighters and feather
rate MMA fighters and having them fight
each other it's fucked up dude we're
like we're made of knives we're Edward's
fucking Scissorhands we shouldn't be
fighting with like fragile molested sex
symbols the Aging sex symbols that need
money that's like yeah fucked up I
shouldn't be roasting Pam Anderson
publicly it's humiliating when a comic
grows a comic that's a fucking fair
fight yeah you know what I mean and
that's what it felt like it was really
fun it was so fun and then I want to
make sure everyone was protected in
terms of like I had look at us the only
rules the best time out only rules are
you're not calling men pedophiles right
you're not calling them rapists yeah
because no one here I'm not including
anyone that has Shady background shit
right this is not happening smarts smart
right I mean for once I it took me it
took me 20 years to read the writing on
the fucking wall
um so no calling women that are 40 olds
right it's like you know what I mean
yeah and no and no food is like number
one yeah and there's no there's no like
face jokes remember that was there were
face jokes they just have to be yeah so
here's the thing if it doesn't ring true
it's not funny yeah so if someone's like
Whitney got 50 facelifts it's like that
was a very part of the Rose was when you
come to writers and be like guys I have
not had a facelift I will but not yet
when I've had a facelift everyone will
know I will be sponsored by Neosporin
and it will be all over the place like
what do you mean the best face joke was
Matt Harrow with his face which one
Whitney's drag name yeah Whitney's drag
name is Botox Botox horse face
Zach Amico had some fucking killer so
for me it was like okay let's go after
Whitney's face okay
uh saying I'm old is like it's just not
true right I mean but you had one of the
best jokes which was like about it like
like Dan was so fucking clever about it
here's the other thing about roast is
like they stop the friar slip roast
everyone were truly friends and you
could feel it like yeah words mean
nothing it's like that's what it felt
like when we were doing like I felt like
I was like it was so much fun and the
crowd I felt like dude could feel too
because it was just so it was so
beautiful they were loving it yeah you
could tell we were like jumping out of a
plane together which we have kind of
done yeah we've actually done
check out our last podcast together
um but uh it was like it was like
roasting is very delicate because it's
like you don't know me like that like
yeah Dan can say things to me that no
one else can say to me you know so Dan
saying uh Whitney um uh what was it
Whitney everyone thinks Whitney's on
drugs
um the sad part is she's actually not on
drugs it's like even more embarrassing
because how do you send someone to rehab
for their personality exactly who pays
for the intervention you bet she vemos
herself yeah like it just was like so
that was like the perfect way to like do
that yeah it was it was fun I mean do
you like was there any time that you
were like what have I done in the middle
of it at all or no or no the only time
during it and we haven't like edited all
yet the only time during it was the fact
that I was like uh I for because I
wanted to do the crowd is crucial so I
think that I I like to just again like
fix the mistakes that I saw made because
I came up watching people that made the
roast made TV shows made these big
movies and I'm watching the mistakes
they're making and I'm watching why and
I'm like this is so unfair to the
viewers at home yeah like because these
people just are so fucking dumb so the
ego of like the audience the audience
matters yeah right oh yeah so I was like
the people in the audience that the
people at home don't even see affects
the performance of the people they do
see remember the guy there's a guy in
the front row with sunglasses and you
were like you could sit in the front row
but you cannot move do not move she's in
the middle of like a roast and she's
like screaming I knew that guy was a
fucking problem and then the guy moved I
knew it was a problem I knew it was a
problem from the fucking beginning so
you always want to control the first
three rows of a production because of
course yeah they're on camera and so I
had it all be clowns I want to remind
people so the people that are like
comedians like you're punching down duh
Joe Rogan is spreading miss him from the
were clowns dumb dumb and we're not
fucking politicians we're not go after
the politics do that like I want to
remind people that we are idiots and
we're silly gooses who are like the
philosophers that are the referees of
culture where the the referees of
culture were really fucking smart but
stop don't take us too seriously we just
point out the problem it's someone
else's job to solve the problem it's not
our job we illuminate the problems make
you laugh about us what the court
Chester was designed to do the Court
Jester was designed to deliver bad news
to the king in a way that wouldn't make
him so mad that he like started a
fucking War right away didn't make him
like shut down you know but he got the
great hats and they had those great hats
I love those hats the like flask of
dickhead there was a period of time
where those were popular again they
would sell them in the stores like Mary
go around in the mall and I remember
there was a period of time where I was
like I always at the mall I love the
mall I love them all you're the only
person I know that goes to the mall I
love going it was just a shooting at one
I love what will it take I love going to
the mall the shootings the molesters
they can't stop me from entering a mall
and getting a Wetzel malt I feel like
malls have evolved into like many little
Disneylands they've evolved into
websites
because it's like you don't need to go
to the mall anymore no a lot of them are
not great but I still enjoy going with
kids it's like playgrounds and like you
know but the playgrounds in the mall are
disgusting it's like you go there to get
RSV like it's not even for me I just
like kind of like walk into a mall like
sort of the Nostalgia of being like all
right let's go into this shoe store but
even like the stores don't even have
anything this reminds me of the damn
men's joke of when he invented the
restaurant like when every now and then
um you invent something that's been
around forever so like uh Dory Howard uh
best friend OG Mafia uh called me one
day and she's like hey I just invented
them all I was like what and she was
like she was like you buy everything
online whatever which I don't use Amazon
anymore I just use Etsy you can get
everything on Amazon from Etsy toilet
paper really olive oil everything it
might come wrapped in a diaper depends
but you know and if you it might be a
little moist when you open it right but
it's mom-owned native owned black owned
so I do everything I come in hemp you
might it will smell like incense it
might come and use tampons like it might
but it's you can get all the same shit
just be careful if you open it glitter
might fly everywhere yeah you're a bit
you're a big Etsy but Etsy is like
Amazon but you're it's small businesses
yeah you know they have everything you
could possibly need yeah I get
everything from there yeah you are a big
Etsy Everything Herbs so much horse
stuff toothbrushes everything so much
more stuff yeah and um who cares who
care and I don't feel guilty like when
you see those Amazon drivers like just
like shitting in a cup as they run your
fucking eyeliner to you that was just
tested on animals and shine in a cup
you're just like I feel bad it makes me
feel bad when you you know when you
order one fucking pencil and it's in a
bag and then three plastic things not
huge my entire life is just breaking
down Amazon box it's wild it's all I do
nonsense why are we doing this you know
so it's just like it makes me feel bad
right like I feel like guilty when I do
that I'm like everything from Etsy now
everything you might just have to plan
ahead a couple days
yeah because you're getting like cloth
toilet paper are you the person that did
the joke about Zappos like a shoes and I
got them yesterday no but I wish I were
to choose from Zappos and I got them
yesterday
she's like how the fuck did they get
here so fast but here's here's the thing
now now we're definitely on a weird
online shopping tangent but I will tell
you that it's such a way I waste so much
time buying things that don't fit I I
bought my wife but four different shoes
this year for Hanukkah and none of them
fit now it's like I'm boxing and put
them back it's like it would be it'd be
better as like if we just go somewhere
and you try them on in person you just
get them there like I think it's like
yeah we had that already yeah but it's I
think we got to go back back to analog
some things were better before you know
what I mean that's my whole thing with
my house with like a lot of like Tech
stuff I go oh this was better before
like we tried out the tech version and
like it actually worked better before
yeah like I had that like I'm using a
notebook and Pen this is bad yeah like
can I just use a doorbell yeah so so you
know I'm at your house because then it's
like the ring at the Wi-Fi it's like the
doorbell like can I ring a bell like a
like a manual guys knock knock because
there's so many times where I'm like hey
I've rung your ring like five times like
oh sorry with my phone on my phone I
don't hear you I'm like I'm laughing my
phone I left you're gonna do the ring
camera thing of a doorbell you have to
the phone has to be charged yeah the
Wi-Fi has to be working
provider there's like so many variables
that have to be in play that
billionaires that have pedophile Yachts
make money off of us doing okay but you
know what I mean so it's like I just
feel too guilty doing I'm like there is
a simpler way it's it takes really smart
people to reduce something down to
something very simple
you know what I mean yes also your wife
can buy her own shoes that is true
like I'm big on Christmas I'm like do
not get me any if I want something I
have it yeah get me something thoughtful
or an act of service
or by the way go to therapy for yourself
like the shirt I got you thoughtful this
is Dan's Christmas gift to me brought a
tear to my eye I didn't think I had any
left he managed to conjure the last tier
I tried he but the last tier I was was
that weird when I start my eyes started
watering yeah that was crazy yeah well
you you you you've had a a rough few
weeks I didn't cry when my mom died and
then you gave me a Greg Geraldo crew
shirt and I cried yeah you know so this
is comic book this is a Dan getting me a
vintage shirt that means something
symbolic to me that's the thing and then
I get to wear it on the podcast and then
it's great yeah I mean this was
definitely made by Chinese children but
like but that was 20 years ago someone
definitely died in that shirt for sure
but you know what when I saw it at this
cool Houston vintage shop I was like
common relief is this like big comedy
like charity thing and on the back has
all the comedians names and Andrew Dice
Clay is his it's not energized it's Andy
clay no Andrew Clay yeah he's not nice
yet that's how old this shirt is wow
crazy it's giving me cancer that must
have been a big deal when he was like
dice I gotta add the dice Andrew just
Clay is like
I mean he is a fucking amazing actor
yeah amazing actor yeah like that was
the fuck he got kind of that's a tricky
one
he's he's great though isn't he and
stuff yeah he's doing he's using stuff a
lot yeah I guess he works a lot but he's
like I feel bad back to the Jeremy Hots
I feel some compassion for the people
that kind of did like characters for
lack of a better word and had to stick
to that character like Paulie Shore like
you know what I mean yeah I feel like
we're so lucky that we post um like what
Marlon Brando did for acting like what
Richard Pryor did for comedy we get to
be like ourselves and we don't have to
be like I'm this person that puts a
banana on my head and then right you're
trapped and people think we're
characters but we're actually the same
yeah this is who I am I'm sorry it's
even worse how do you go to rehab for
your personality
okay so the roast of me okay so it was
do and I'm not saying don't call 40 year
old women old and don't call men
pedophiles because it's I'm this like
woke police person it's just not gonna
get the laugh because it's not true you
know what I mean and it's not I want
everyone in the Deus to know that
they're safe from like an accusation for
no reason yeah you know so I was like
you don't get Jim Norton and David tell
and you know all these people unless
they're like I don't want to be in a
roast everyone's gonna call me a
pedophile and a rapist and do these
racist shit I don't want to be a part of
that and so if I could promise them
you're protected yeah and this will
always be a like above the belt like we
could go the hardest it's like
uh it's like I remember one time Seth
Meyer's brother Josh yeah
um he uh I heard a story about you know
the person at game night who's like
takes it super seriously yeah I think
he's one of those okay I'm kind of one
of those yeah I'm the person that's like
well what are we are we here to win are
we fucking around it's like this is
really fucking Mafia someone's gonna
fucking die I well Mafia is you know my
story about Mafia playing the game Mafia
yeah
um it's ruined my life because I won I I
I if I'm going to game night are we I
just need to know are we fucking around
are we playing to win so if you're going
like time and then I don't like game
nights I just want to hang out one night
at a game night with Adele oh wow she
plays to win hello have you ever
it's me have you ever here's the funny
thing about celebrity game nights and
they happen all the time in LA it's like
a big thing the number one game they
like to play is what
Mafia
celebrity celebrity
it's so fucking weird when celebrities
like let's play Celebrity and you write
down celebrities names and they're all
there and everybody has to do the cue
like everyone has to do it I think I did
it Ashton Kutcher's house one time when
I was on Punk and it was like Bruce
Willis and Demi Moore and like all that
and literally the celebrity name will
come up and you'll be like
he's in the bathroom
he wait um are you an affair with him he
imploded your marriage okay there was a
rumor that you cheated uh uh with her on
the set of um uh Invincible like you're
literally doing that
it's fucking ridiculous and then so so
yeah so the rules so
um Josh I heard is one of the people
that go
like games need rules that's what makes
them fun right you know what I mean if
you don't have rules in place it turns
into chaos so it's like a little bit of
rigidity is how everyone can be free and
I remember always like I don't know Neil
Brandon whoever told me like I'm that
person too I'm like if we don't have
rules everyone's stressed out yeah so
let's just do the rules and do this
right
I could definitely see you at a game
night being not great
thank you I
content are we playing to win because I
I have less goes back to the sports
thing I have a sports mentality you have
the winning mentality sure so but if
we're fucking around that's fine but if
we're not I mean Alison Brie remember
when Alison Brie was on and she was like
I feel like you were mad at me
um at that game night at Jessica
albaum's house and I was like I was I
was mad at you because we did like a
game night and she like took an edible
and was like having the best time ever
but not focused I for the first time I
was the sober person at the party yeah
and I was like trying to win this game
and she was like having a good time
it was like charades or something I was
like Focus up like I was so much intense
and she was like she was just like on an
edible like having a good time and I was
like
twixted in between
um okay so we do the roast picking the
Deus of the roast was like really kind
of wild because I was like
if I'm gonna do this the stakes are so
high because I could look like a fucking
narcissist real fast if I only pick
number one my friends that are gonna
take it easy on me and people that like
Anne because I'm controlling it I'm
technically like head you know like
writing on it I have final cut on it
like so I was like it has to be people I
know are gonna go hard on me and
different people that are like
you know influential in different
sectors of Comedy even ones that I'm not
in yeah it was a diverse group of
comedians not diverse in race but yeah
diversity comedy audience you if there's
not someone from Legion of skanks on
this I'm cheating right Jeremy like
Legion of skanks is like you know the
ones that go hard hardest yeah and how
would you explain legionist gangs yeah I
think that they're that that's kind of
what they are they're like the most
offensive group of cops yeah whatever
that's that's what they say that's yeah
courageous no holds bar like
demonetized Shadow band uh motherfuckers
like and Louis J Gomez so it's like and
then a big Jay oakerson being on birds
it's like if you don't have someone from
that you're just like taking it easy on
yourself it's like a you know it's like
taking steroids in sports or something
yeah yeah and so then you you put
together a group of people that you
really like and then we all just
destroyed you for an hour and a half and
it was so funny it was so funny Hannah's
talking was really funny it was like
it I can't even explain it like it's
like being tickled or something like
Robin Tran too she she cries Bob and
Tran this is I want to put an end to
this whole like trans versus comedy
thing because like Rob and Tran is who's
gonna end all this dude Robin Tran like
this whole thing that like trans people
can't be joked about it's not fucking
true you know this I'm shooting a
special in a couple months like about
trans drag all that kind of stuff and
it's like and I have a joke in it that's
I'm still working on it about like trans
people can take a joke it just has to be
a funny joke has to be well thought out
and you just can't be an asshole like
yeah I have a friend who's trans and you
would never know she's trans
or like you would never fucking know but
every now and then you know you know
like um the other day we uh we went to
the mall and she like backed into a
parking space and I was like
if I can saw that like I saw that I just
want you to know that I fucking saw that
I go to her apartment and like her
bathtub she has like one sliver of Irish
Spring soap from like seven years ago so
I'm like
you are totally a woman wouldn't have
thought otherwise but just so you know
you might wanna you might even get rid
of the the thing of comet on your
bathtub from 12 years ago like your mug
of pennies like your first joke yeah
your bowl of pennies with like your high
school fucking football ring yeah and
the like the every time I like put like
change into like a mug I'm like I think
about that joke from like 2005. that's
one of my favorite jokes it's one of
those jokes where you're like when you
think of it like you know those jokes
where you think of it and you're like I
can't believe I thought and I call all
my comic friends I'm like have you heard
this have you heard like there's no way
I'm the person that thought of this like
there's no way so like the phone book
joke in my last thing yeah people are
afraid of privacy we used to have a
phone book of everyone's phone numbers
and they would throw at your house like
you're like
how did I just think of that yeah that's
so crazy yeah I'm like I feel so like
psyched like I know that I didn't think
of this I like just got it somehow yeah
yeah it's a great moment I was just
excited because I was like
when you when you put the um what's it
called like the parameters of like can't
make fun of you can but also the other
thing is like
if you're gonna do a joke about my face
and my whatever tits uh being a drug
addict you know whatever that shit is
only two or three can really make the
cut you know what I mean so the best
ones are gonna make it so I didn't want
a bunch of comics
to work on a bunch of jokes that aren't
going to make it in right so it's like
we used to do the roast back in the day
like with Geraldo Jeff Ross like the
biggest thing was like
there's 10 AIDS quilts jokes we can only
have one AIDS quilt Joe yeah in the
whole show so the best May the best one
win right and like if I know that Dan
has the best you know Whitney's face
joke I gotta tell everyone else like lay
off the face stuff because I'm gonna
have to cut it anyway yeah you know what
I mean because like I don't want people
to and when you're actually performing
it Dan's already done a killer uh
Whitney's face uh Michael Jackson
Halloween mask whatever the fuck her
face is yeah yeah by the time you go up
it's not gonna be as funny because he
already did it yeah you know what I mean
like you have to like
like this is something that bothered me
as like in the roast and stuff no one
cared about the performers
experience and their performance
experience is what makes it electric for
the viewers at home yeah so I wanted the
audience to be all invite only comedy
people small room because like what the
fuck is why the roasts which I love they
I think gave me a career for the most
part like John Rivers where I was like
Comics we get we're the funniest in
smaller events because people that I
didn't even realize but the roast
remember even the Whitney sitcom it
would come back to the wedding sitcom
you were not supposed to be in that then
the roasts came out
and it was the MBC executive who said
you should just be in the sitcom do you
remember that yes I wrote it it was
called just angle I love Jeff Engel well
yeah because I was like No One's Gonna
I'm an unknown like like like scumbag
dirt bag comedy girl No One's Gonna put
me in it so I wrote it was called five
years and the character's name was dot I
remember that remember I wrote it for me
and crystalia and I uh pitched them the
whole show and I was like Oh They'll
cast you know jet Elfman or Andrew
accidentally on purpose I'll finally get
an audition whoever drove into Aubry
Plaza is Opera available to play Whitney
like
and then they go well why don't you just
play the part and when they said do you
want to play the role of Whitney in the
show this show I'm like oh they're
obviously not gonna make it like that
that I took that as a well if they're
hiring me it must mean that they don't
believe in it and they just have to like
burn off this well because you always
you've heard those stories in the past
where people write a show for themselves
and they have to test for it and they
don't get it sure you know so like Bobby
Kelly just told the story uh Robert
Kelly who's just on the podcast he was
telling the story on his podcast about
that with Dane Cook oh yeah yeah you had
to go and audition to play himself and
didn't get it yeah yeah
it's just like which is like I just
assumed yeah you know like so then there
because also like Studios and networks
this is something a lot of people don't
know they have a certain amount of money
that they need to spend quarterly and if
they don't spend it they they don't get
to keep the money right right and then
they order something and then they have
to make it or not or else they lose it
and there used to be this crazy
scheduling thing in television where it
was like you had to get shows on at a
certain time streaming now you can Louis
CK like
and he was doing like uh not lucky Louie
which I loved but uh what's his show in
FX oh Louie Louie yeah yeah he literally
released it when it was ready yeah we
used to have to go like this has to come
out September 7th no you you would refer
to it as pencils down pencils down
comedy yeah because it was we were on a
real schedule I think you know they had
to deliver a show in a you had like
three months to make it you only had a
certain amount of money it was like
fucking Hunger Games it was like you had
a certain amount of money you had to
spend a certain amount of time or you'd
lose it
everyone will get fired you had a show
you had to get on the area it's just
like a pressure cooker for like
creativity crazy I mean sometimes you
know sometimes it does work like it is
fun to be like that that energy and have
that adrenaline you know but it is it's
just it's it's long It's a Grind yeah
it's fun to have the adrenaline I think
there's ways to get that adrenaline
other ways that don't hurt anyone and
you're hurting you're in you're it's
just the audience suffers ultimately
yeah we get paid we're fine the audience
at home is like wait what I like I'm I'm
sitting here in my children why did you
guys Rush this at me
why did you get me do you need more it's
like it's like a it's like a waiter yeah
like you guys need more time it's like a
waiter delivering your food like half
cooked you're like this it's my birthday
can you take your time what you need to
do to make this edible
we never did that we're like yeah here's
a half done show by a bunch of talented
people yeah and we hurt everyone in the
process everyone's bleeding everything
the show's not even good like what's
what is this circle jerk shit just make
a good show humanely hey everyone and
then put it out when it's ready
why not that's what happened here only
fans the roast of Whitney Cummings free
so the only fan just FYI that's the
other thing I want to make sure it was
free oh it's gonna be free it's free so
only fans TV is a separate thing so I
have my only fans account and that's
just my pictures and like my video and
stuff that I most of my only fans
account is just jokes that I can't put
on YouTube Netflix all those other
places the cities freak out yeah because
people lose their mind Oxnard we'll
figure this out Oxnard California
Oxnard California and I are in a little
bit of a duel you guys could make up I
feel like you you're not too far from it
you could drive down there hug everyone
in Oxnard I have to I think meet with
the mayor the mayor of us on local
television and explain what happened
with the Oxnard Saga okay
well that'll be good content
will it will it be I don't know how you
get yourselves in these situations you
have to meet with the mayor boxer on
live television like what's going on
you need a new manager
my manager
owns
[Laughter]
oxygen over
it's a nightmare the first time that's
ever happened I love you yeah Judy
marmel I love exactly yeah I was like I
made a shout out video to Oxnard it
really my mistake on the Oxnard Saga was
um
I was ignorant about so I've been going
to Oxnard okay Oxnard okay sorry look up
your fucking jokes Oxnard is a city yes
in California that is right next to
Santa Barbara yes okay
Santa Barbara is within Santa Barbara is
Montecito
yes one of the wealthiest areas in the
world Megan and Harry live there Oprah
lives there there's Bronze Statues that
line
there's ostriches running free like it's
it's Ellen can't stop flipping homes hey
Ellen Ellen oh
um
so it's like it's it's um I don't know
Narnia for for wealthy the wealthiest I
mean it's the wealthiest wealthiest
wealthiest people yes and then uh I
don't think it's I think it's kind of a
shit a lot
like the waves aren't they do it again
no but the waves aren't big like you get
there and you're like what is the draw
like I'm confused like I grew up without
money like I grew up in kind of a um
simulacra of money and grew up in
department stores and even Marcus's yeah
lies and cons yeah cons and but like I
saw a lot of wealth but like I'm not
sure why wealthy people want to live
there there's something we don't know
right because it's not like the most
beautiful place in the world
it's not what's the proximity to is that
where the underground tunnel pedophile
tunnel comes up like I I don't know this
is not the kind of things you got to say
on the public because the news what's
why Santa Barbara it's the tunnels like
what about standard why do all rich
people um in California gravitate to
Santa Barbara there's a lot of open Land
open land so it's beautiful so they can
they can get their illegals to work on
them no it's beautiful you see the ocean
there's a great town
um Vineyards Vineyards Vineyards there's
wine there's there's everything Santa
Barbara's beautiful
sure I love it my screensaver has all
that yeah everything you're saying my
screen saver between go puff and the
screensaver I've got it go pop so help
me I'm trying to understand genuinely
it's a beautiful place to live La Jolla
I get a little more it's no it's a
tradition it's tradition no Santa
Barbara is a beautiful place it's like
they they have they have everything you
want in sort of a vacation so not
everything I want you have the ocean I'm
also like not a Hamptons person you have
like a downtown but it's different than
Hamptons it's not as
hamptony
um I don't know I like Santa Barbara but
I also know that well you're an 80 year
old Jewish woman it's not you would it's
not Oxnard but there are beautiful parts
of Oxnard I don't know
I'm a mountain lady I don't the sea I
have no I don't like it I know we've
already discussed at length the issue
with the ocean I've watched my mom and
hospice die looking at the ocean and I
don't get it
it's redundant it's just like wave after
it just keeps it just like never ends
it's like now what another wave another
wave like are you really going after the
ocean it's just it's just like
monotonous it's like and then there's
another wave it's relaxing beautiful
like is it it stresses me the fuck out
okay because the water level is rising
all I see when I look at the ocean is
like uh you're gonna you're coming for
me
that's your you have your own issues
with with something happened to you I
think it all goes down to this guy in
Schenectady you took your virginity on
the water I think that's what we're
learning today when you look at the
ocean you feel serene
yeah I find it wrong the ocean would
kill you in a fucking heartbeat no I
know I don't I I know it's scary but I
don't know someone's gonna swim deep in
the ocean I'm just gonna like put my
little feet in what good has ever
happened in the ocean name one thing
uh treasure chests
enough about my tits
well like what what has ever positively
happened in the ocean
I I don't know name it pat
you lost your virginity in the ocean on
uh that's true on a Carnival Cruise that
was people love why was that that was a
good thing
it had to happen at some point on the
ocean people love water skiing they love
motor boating they love
testing the American Health Care System
yes they do I don't think
many people have these weird ocean
feelings that you do but I I do know
when my son was two he was scared of
waves so you're right clearly you know
you kids
children no they're like this is bad
news and we're like no no go in it and
they're like I don't know man kids are
born with all the instincts
they're born perfect and then we go no
no no swim in the enemy
go swim in this in this I I know Mercury
what I'm now an Oxnard side
it's
of You by the way I am looking at
property in Oxnard that's a great irony
of all this there you go my lawyer lives
there yeah uh am I allowed to say this
uh Carl Austin has a house there okay
look at that lawyer yes I know he was
your lawyer he's my lawyer everyone's
lawyer love that fucking guy he loved
the roast love him he was wearing a
cowboy hat yes he was loving it all ah
you know what I I lawyers like I have
such a weird relationship with lawyers
because you're constantly being sued
and um uh there are some good ones the
one from the staircase the documentary
staircase that lawyer he should be your
lawyer I've tried I have such a crush
I'm too Starstruck I have such a crush
on him the Pepsi um documentary on
Netflix have you seen it Pepsi Points
documentary where's Pepsi where's my jet
I don't know Pat yeah I watched it hat
is it good it's really good it's fucking
excellent I want to have I want to have
Michael avenetti you want to have
Michael have an audience dying to that
would be great he's on house arrest he
has many wait he he's um he's in he was
involved in the Pepsi Points case yeah
but wasn't he the lawyer Daniels he's in
jail yeah he's house arrest right now we
just did a house arrest episode with
Anna delvey we don't need we have a
whole house arrest series that's a cool
thing you will go to homes of people who
are under house arrest
I mean you're under house arrest I mean
it makes sense surely I've never rested
a day in my life what's it called Pepsi
Points Pepsi no Pepsi where's my jet
Pepsi where's my jet I'm dying to know
what you think okay and Pepsi I'm
talking to you right now
the fact that I'm not the CEO of Pepsi
is shocking but is it pat pat are you
with me
what's Pepsi's next move right now
they're gonna try to take you out
apparently me yeah what if you're Pepsi
that documentary comes out what do you
do
they're gonna run another points game
they're gonna do that would be your
chest move yeah I haven't seen it
correctly if I'm the CEO of Pepsi right
now
I give a jet to that guy
I go I'm sorry
I everything that happened before me I
wasn't involved
and we're gonna uh fix the fucking uh
was it the Philippines well that's the
thing that they would on they would
unbox that whole problem if they solved
this one guy's problem they'd have to go
solve the yeah we're gonna give you that
we're gonna give you the the jet
just for fun for your yard
but then somebody would say oh if you
admitted that this one was bad on your
part let's go back to the Philippines
and correct that we're gonna do but we
gotta do it all yeah you have you have
there's reparations to be made they
would that would destroy that they would
not be a corporation after the
Philippines to recover from that one
I haven't seen it so I can they go if
I'm Pepsi CEO I go hey I'm I'm coming in
hot here I have I know everything I'm
doing I'm only taking this position to
make things right
okay so this jet we're gonna have here
and all and people are gonna come by and
take pictures with the Jet and all the
money from the photos that are taking
the pictures with this jet is going to
go to the Philippines
and we're going to redistribute that
wealth there
right uh we'd have to check the large
number math on the amount to recover I
think there were thousands of people
that technically won their Be A
Millionaire competition yep and it was
like a printing glitch or whatever but
they technically won so they would have
to go and make thousands of people
millionaires with interest because that
was in the 90s so if you want a million
bucks in the 90s that million dollars is
worth way more today than it uh the
number is greater today to match the
inflation from that long ago but then
you gotta go
stunned on that and go why did Pepsi do
all that in the first place because
Coca-Cola
did some wildly fucking sneaky shit
um
uh how about zoa I love zoa The Rock's
energy drink
they're chill right
[Laughter]
I've been drinking a lot of zoa lately I
haven't seen this documentary so it's
controversial so I I I can't I can't
comment on the Pepsi documentary but
just heads up I love zoa so did the
Fanta girls get paid for those
commercials I was an acting class with
one of them
I was in acting class with the great
Fanta girl
and I remember finding out she was a fan
of girl and being like Oh my God this is
amazing you meant grape I met grape I
forget her name she was nice hope she's
doing well remember in the member in the
Whitney's writer's room when we're
trying to come up with a nickname for um
uh me and Alex's character Crystal Lee's
character okay and uh like what would we
call each other and you were like crazy
Thief said grape
I think I did say great I was like we
would call each other peanut nut little
buddy great I love grape I was like
everyone was like
[Laughter]
great it doesn't even roll off the
tongue grape grape hey grapey like what
that makes me think crepey skin
um okay so cold Wars okay so so
Coca-Cola
um uh cold Awards long time rivalry
between Cola producers the Coca-Cola
Company PepsiCo so this went on Rogan uh
the guy that wrote it went on Rogan and
it's called what's the book called
um so Coca-Cola they fucking did this
wild dude so fucking smart and when we
say they I hate when people they did
this thing I'm like who who I know what
they means they means like four people
but there was one person what a name you
know it's like they made that show who
there's one person that signed off on it
what's their name and you know
everything did they play team sports
what's their ancestry or their only
child I need to know their birth order
let me get that fucking guy because they
is how we like defuse responsibility
from someone
um so Coke and Pepsi what Coke did was
they made a deal with the government
during I think it was the Vietnam War or
was it Desert Storm to provide Coke as
the official drink of the soldiers at
War okay okay so that when
the soldiers came back they had diabetes
if they didn't just die yeah
um uh of BDS like I wish that worked um
and so they came back and their kids
drink a Coke I'm sorry
and they come back take two
and then they come back and their kid is
drinking a Pepsi get that Pepsi out of
your hand you drink fucking Coke it's
their kid you know what I mean oh wow
what are you gay
we drink Coke in this house so coke
became associated with like patriotism
in America that's how I am with zoa
I beat my kids and they don't drink zoa
like give me the fruit punch Flavor now
Daddy needs his zoa
come on
I'm amped up at all times
[Laughter]
I'm just saying yellow people it is yes
the middle finger from from the sitcom
yes the moment that we just made just
now is a very magical moment yes this is
a prop from the NBC sitcom Whitney where
when Crystal Lee's character proposed to
me uh or I put a ring on my finger it
was about a girl who was afraid to be a
role reversal gender reversal Emily
Nussbaum you didn't get it Emily
Nussbaum you didn't get it
you didn't get it and that's okay I
forgive you we forget others not because
they deserve forgiveness because we
deserve peace but
um and then as soon as I put the ring on
my finger broke was that the story yes
and so this is the prosthetic finger
I was very into nail polish it was very
important to me uh and this is a
prosthetic finger
look at it for it it'll go in a museum
no day
oh no I have questions as well a lot of
things in museums can we return to the
people
um so yeah okay the soda Wars thing
that's whole thing also I think Coke um
the guy explained on Rogan the the leaf
that makes Coke taste like what it
tastes like
they have some um what's it called when
something's like a lock you have a lock
on something or like a it's been
cornered cornered the market like no one
else can use that leaf
like it's it's patented
um the cocoa Leaf the people that grow
the cocoa Leaf they can only sell it to
Coke
exclusively yep so they can't they have
no left they can't sell to anyone else
so they can't charge more I gotta watch
this documentary and then come back on
the Pod yeah because I can't follow what
anything it's all talking about it's a
lot I know Coke Pepsi Wars it's
important all for sugar water like I
don't drink Coke I'd all of this or
Pepsi all of this too much sugar for a
fluid too much sugar all this drama if
you want a good carbonated drink get the
zero sugar zoa
zoa water are we sure I'm positive I
think no I think the one that everyone
this the spend Thrift spin Thrift oh
spin spin spin Thrift spoon spoonie spin
drift
is this this is if Candace Thompson
drinks it I'm on it this feels like a
safe bet it is it's it's it's a nice
little carbonation it has a little bit
of a Lacroix to it
um not no sugar a little little lime but
nice carbs who's who makes what's the
supply chain I need some Trader Joe's
it's Joe Joe who
I have questions
Trader Joe's who's Joe no I don't know
probably Goldstein I need to know the
supply chain of all this okay yeah you
look it up the supply chain of our
phones that like literally child slaves
are making our cell phones
we're literally posting on our phones
about like black lives matter and and
help sex trafficking and help children
on a phone that's made by slaves in the
Congo like pregnant women and children
oh thanks you're welcome now I can think
about that every time I send a text
2023. gotcha okay oh it's 305. okay I
trust this
do I trust this brand yes yes yes you
should be the face spin drift you should
be the face of it but they are racist
against people's speech amendments we're
back to that back to that yeah full
circle here you like the uterine lining
then the spin drift yeah spin drift okay
I don't like feeling guilty for taking
care of myself yeah it's like don't make
don't give me a top a product that take
it I don't want to like be in
participate in baby fingers being
chopped off just because I need water
okay put that
drink out of the tap
all right let's do some of these jokes I
can't imagine there's anything to make
fun
yeah so here here are some of these
jokes
um uh let's do it let's I'm just looking
through here
um but look at Whitney look what you've
done some of these jokes I I said
two jokes that you said on the roast who
cares okay it's gonna be so different
okay great and the crossover the kind of
people the P if you fuck with me you
fuck with me motherfucker so if
someone's listening and they hear the
joke here and they're gonna hear it in
the only fans ropes when we drop it on
the 14th it's still gonna be funny this
one I love because we love Bob so I get
so much Bob sag it was cremated and
Donnell is still ashier than him
that was a fun one the Donnell thing
yeah that was out of control
um I remember when Whitney lived Behind
The Comedy Store and ate carrots and
ketchup she's she she was poor and
anorexic at least she's no longer poor
but you look great you look like the
female president of the UPN show okay
it did kind of in the room like it did
kind of okay UPN was what would what
would be the version today for the
kiddos UPN was like I love that you
refused to be relevant they Dan
Dan's whole fucking thing is I refuse to
be relevant I refused cow Tao to the
next generation's reference points it
was a uh it was a network that was like
you know Network adjacent so it was like
similar to a CW like have being on being
on being a CW Show which also works
saying that you look like you know uh a
president I look but but if they do it a
reference that works and then Pat and I
need time because um I'm a witch or no
you look great you look like the female
president on a CW show that also that's
not a thing anymore either it's not no
no I don't know that I I that reference
doesn't even work you're a combination
of Joan Rivers and Betty Ford that's
hilarious hold on so um why hold on
everyone I want you to see this oh you
want to show yourself I want this on
fucking lock Pat look why can't I click
on this link is this Elon Musk Bezos
who's trying to sabotage me
okay so men okay
the other day
my mom died as my mom is dying by the
way hospice 10 days I'm 11 whatever no
feeding tube
yeah Oxnard her mom died um
and I as my mom is passing okay I'm on
the phone with the furniture delivery
person
it's good timing you had to pick up from
like Serena and Lily or whatever the
fuck yeah and he's trying to deliver
furniture
I'm in the house on the beach don't get
it don't get it uh they're like they're
at my front gate on the ring camera
they're like we need to drop off this
you know
umbrella whatever the fuck it is I'm
like can you leave it at the gate can
you leave at the gate no we can't leave
it to the gate it's the whole thing we
have to take it back to this the
warehouse and we'll reschedule the
delivery what
that means I'm not gonna get this shit
for months if ever ever it never never
happens it goes back to the warehouse
yeah game over Dude you are losing your
600 for that fucking umbrella that's
gonna stop me from getting skin cancer
you're giving me cancer currently as I'm
watching my mom die so I'm like please
drop it off can you take a picture I'll
call your boss who what do I need to do
to get you to drop this off I'm
negotiating with this guy my sister pops
in
no heartbeat one sec just need you to
leave it just need to leave it okay the
spots on her feet you know someone's
dying in hospice when someone's dying um
who's uh pronounced terminal the way
they die is of dehydration
that's how they die slowly die
dehydration spots on the spots on the
feet cool so if you could just drop it
at the gate spots on the feet what uh
spots on the feet
here we go mom's dying tongue is blue
could you just take could what if I know
a t T-Mobile like where I'm arguing with
this guy and then there's a uh my
sister's boyfriend in the room
I'm like can you he goes gets on the
phone with the delivery person goes hey
could you just leave at the gate the guy
goes oh yeah sure cool man
oh my
God so the delivery guy didn't even know
what this guy is
as soon as a guy just said could you
leave it at the gate
over yeah I spent 30 minutes trying to
convince this guy well you know what he
couldn't hear you because you were by
the ocean all the way again the ocean is
your enemy no because then well it
wasn't Santa Barbara there's no fucking
Waves Santa Barbara the waves are these
little pathetic little tiny little
nothing waves it's not it's like a
little
little you know Whitney loves riding
horses it's the only time the dumb
animal between her legs doesn't have a
podcast
here's the problem with that joke
because I was like
the random role of that was the like I
have actually never slept with a
comedian
unless you're gonna
uh not gonna say that but like the bread
and chop jokes that was 10 years ago yes
and do people know about it will it
resonate you know what I mean yeah like
if you're gonna insult someone it just
has to be at it's like the Mind meld
everyone needs to be
like jokes are so fascinating to me
because it's like the Tetris game of
it's only funny if everyone in the
audience knows the reference
uh it's true like so many things have to
like so many stars have to align yeah
and no one has to go wait what she dated
a podcaster like you can't confuse
anyone right it has to be like a clean
shot psychological exactly like this by
the way Whitney taught us an important
lesson a natural disaster always posts
your most heroic acts on Instagram so
good I remember watching Shields the
draft jump over the fence I'll save you
and you could live with me and watch me
do a podcast with Allison Brie and the
draft was like ah I'm okay burning to
death
Allison Brie I forgive you for that game
night
Whitney's house is a pet rescue shelter
it's a kill shelter where all the pets
take their own lives
why are animals attacking you they hate
you but that wasn't me I forgot my ear
was bitten off my Annie yeah that was
really funny
um Whitney is so generous she lets
people
um stay with her for weeks her house is
like an Airbnb for Comics who will
eventually hurt her reputation
it's so good
um yeah I I'm uh oh yeah I met witty in
2004 during an audition for a TV show
called Hell Date which is what she calls
her birthday
[Laughter]
when you published a book I've never
read the
scene Whitney's preface
that's funny it's funny
Britain jokes
Whitney was in a movie called what was
it Unforgettable that is you know it's
like these are more like tweets it's
like so this is part of the reason that
in this
um after the Chris Rock Will Smith thing
everyone's like Chris Rock that was mean
or whatever the fuck I don't know where
anyone stands on anything who cares but
I wanted to film The Writer's room and
film The Writers like doing this going
like oh it's a funny joke but like um No
One's Gonna Get it it's too far it's not
I mean it's too mean for the wrong
reasons whatever like just all the sort
of like uh rig and roll that goes into
US crafting the meanest joke possible
like how respectfully we are when we're
disrespectful right you know what I mean
like how carefully we insult someone and
uh like Chris Rock when the Jada joke
like
he could have that was like the nicest
there were thousands of jokes oh yeah
that were written that he passed on
doing for a Litany of reasons and I
wanted to document which is why we're
gonna do the writers we shot the
writer's room of everyone pitching jokes
and like the psychology of why we pick
what we picked so you'll see that it
wasn't just because Chris Rock being
like Jade is bald joke it's not a sloppy
thing right put a lot of effort into
picking the hardest part of watching the
Whitney sitcom was not the show it was
the person she wheeled down to Gumby
weight where all her bones were Pokey by
eating only powdered peanut butter her
own sadness that was too long I didn't
say that one but it's like that's so
Inside Yes I used to eat powder peanut
butter yeah exactly Whitney fucked with
a raccoon and they had to give her a
rabie shot the raccoon not Whitney
she lies she's frantic she's too thin
it's like she skipped the fun hey let's
do drugs phase went right to the hey
should we have an intervention phase
that's funny Whitney you're chronically
single why do I always look like a real
housewife of Transylvania
when he has 13 specials eight are here
tonight
Whitney is less stable than an apartment
building in Miami Beach when you hooked
up with brenshaw which is proof she
doesn't hook up with comedians
that's a good drag queen name Dill is
filler that's funny yeah
um uh I said yes to this because I'm
scared of Winnie that's funny I made
tick tocks not to be confused with these
are like notes we're reading off like no
like writers I am the only one on this
Deus who's actually friends with Whitney
and has hair and not on Megan's Law
like Megan's Law I feel like that was a
reference it's like it's a reference is
that a universal reference
National National Megan's Law is like if
someone's a pedophile they have to
uh did Megan get pedophiled who's Megan
she's a murder victim and they pass
legislation about I think it's about
stalkers you're miked right
yeah I have a mic right here I believe I
believe it let's make sure we hear this
horrible story prior to that case I I'm
not 100 sure I'll look it up but I think
prior to that case the there was no
proper way of registering like somebody
is stalking me and threatening I thought
it was pedophiles
see let's see so so right being in the
writer's room you learn a lot you know
or being in your podcast or your
producer totally because it's like
because you're like oh the Holocaust
yeah it is a way to it's registering sex
offenders sex offenders I think there
was something about it that's nothing to
do with underage her case I think it was
something about her case where someone
with a history of violent sexual crimes
wasn't in a database so there was no way
to like report somebody then have them
say like oh you just reported this
person they happen to have all these
cases sure and it makes sense that
they're being a problem so we should go
intervene and then Amber Alert is
kidnapping kidnapping which is a kid or
an adult oh still kidnapping like the
Megan's Law reference like you're like
wait a second like it doesn't if it
doesn't hit you have to figure out why
like the forensics you have to do to go
like the Megan's Law joke it didn't
people didn't laugh why because they
don't remember it because it's not the
right reference because we've been
getting this reference wrong this whole
time like it's just such a like
fascinating thing and then we have to
start googling like the amount of times
in writer's rooms I've spent two hours
learning about the Armenian Genocide
because I'm trying to write a holocaust
joke but there's already one great
Hitler joke and it's like okay let's
make it the Armenian Holocaust then but
I have to make sure it's the right
reference it's just like but then see
with within your writer's rooms you're
laughing and you're learning we're
laughing um I like this one too um uh
Whitney's career is a Ponzi scheme she's
burning face off
don't judge a book by its cover and
don't judge a comic by her breast
implants Whitney's been in Showbiz so
long I remember when she made transition
to color
[Laughter]
um I was there when Whitney um shot her
special and I was there when she sued
the people who produced that special
[Laughter]
actually a really good person she does
Equine Therapy with sexual assault
survivors because that's exactly what
you want to do after getting raped
reverse cowgirl
[Laughter]
I don't think anyone did that joke I
don't know why I don't know why Whitney
wasn't always successful Whitney
supported herself when she moved to La
by participating in focus groups can you
believe there was a time where people
paid Whitney to hear her opinions or can
you believe there's a time of Whitney
would focus
there's time where Whitney wanted to be
a part of a group oh I like this joke
and then I have to accused him is wrong
to drown in a bathtub wait I I've known
Whitney a long time I knew her before
she found her comedic voice back when
she used to speak at a regular volume I
love that joke so much because you're
loud it's funny uh Whitney could take
the Ellen generous spot we call her
yelling it's like that's a good written
it's like funny but it's like too much
of a pun oh this is this is one of the
biggest laughs when I said a lot of
people saying Whitney's only friend
that's not true we are acquaintances but
that's only funny because we're such
good fucking friends yeah I love that
joke
um people loved it
oh uh uh this is interesting these are
all like notes about me about Donnell I
have literally a hundred wait
33 175 words page okay Jim Norton yeah
it's like a lot it's like it's so weird
like the number of jokes that like go to
waste drive me nuts I know there's so so
yeah I know because there's so much
funny shit and I'm like I always want to
find a home like Johnny Carson always
said like there's no such thing as a a
wasted joke like if something
The Comedians we write like tons and
tons of jokes all day long but if it
doesn't make it on stage it doesn't make
the cut to a special or an hour or to
being performed it'll always like an a
what do you say an a I'm sorry a B plus
joke on stage becomes an a joke if you
say it extemporaneously later right you
know what I mean like it never it never
is I also like this and then I have to
go because I have to pee and I have to
leave but um I'm going first because I'm
the only person on the day with a job or
a family why that is but it's so fucking
funny and then you're like uh and you're
like my wife will be mad to the day a
wife but that's all in performance
that's all performance and like this is
this is where we're getting wrong as
comedians is that when we're like it's
hard to be a comedian now because you
say stuff that's not funny without the
context and without the performance and
we keep giving jokes for free to people
on Twitter written so we're leaving it
up to fans or comedy fans or non-comedy
fans to deliver the joke yeah and to
like add contacts and all this shit yeah
you know like that's the magic of Live
Comedy comedy's supposed to be live it's
not supposed to be tweeted in all this
shit come on entertainment it's supposed
to be live at 9pm in a fucking hole a
gutter in the whole downstairs with like
some very unstable people sitting in the
background yeah with covet on your straw
drinking a Shirley Temple dose with
fentanyl
um oh whoa Dave Hitler didn't uh I
actually was going to do this for Dan
Levy okay Hitler didn't want to kill
your ancestors he knew they just died of
natural causes
that's funny like Dan you're so weak
Hitler didn't even bother burning your
ancestors so you like knew they'd die
eventually of like a sinus infection
that's really like why waste the cold
um about Whitney Whitney's such a
narcissist she's moved to Tears by her
own audiobook Whitney nicknamed her
pussy Sea Biscuit not because she loves
horses because it smells like the ocean
it's been filled with crackers
Jesus Oh the Winnie's MTV Cribs when he
loves horses but it's the networks they
keep saying nay
Whitney's pronouns are He-Man yeah I
love that Whitney the only thing tighter
than your act is your face
the most interesting thing about Whitney
is that we don't know her age oh
Whitney's seven in dog years Whitney I
get lost in your teeth
wait that's funny yeah how dare you when
you might be the first person ever to
have a statue in the wax museum that
looks more real than the actual thing
that's when he's like a hologram and
that people pretend to be impressed by
it she's Hollow Whitney's gonna be
around forever because that's how resin
works
uh the only thing breaking down harder
than Whitney's mental health is David
tells spine don't think more dead than
uh no uh Whitney's dead dad the only
thing more Frozen than her eggs is her
face when he dated a doctor and a
veterinarian she still get gets all her
medical advice from Joe Rogan and she
eats all her pills wrapped in cheese I
love that
oh my god oh do I have to pee okay I I
uh go Whitney's a shining star covered
in oil and constantly decaying
when you got her start by opening for
May West
um I think what we should do is a uh
another podcast with like when it comes
out in February with all the writers me
I think I think me you like Robin Tran
yes like rose a couple maybe Norton
comes out yeah and we like read all the
jokes that got cut yes you know what I
mean like I think we do like a like a
big pie yeah you know what I mean like
Round Table yeah do you think such a
good idea do you think it's good that it
comes out on Valentine's Day oh that's
perfect and I also think I want to call
it this is Pat's suggestion roast is
like I think we retire the notion of the
roast I think it's called the ones we
love yeah because we only we only roast
the ones we love I love that and then I
want to evolve it more towards and I'm
gonna let you go I'm gonna evolve it
more towards um
like surprises Japanese game show shit
yeah because like we mean like the
roasts were great because you got to see
people be fucking mean to each other and
say crazy you can see that all day long
now on Twitter in YouTube comments and
whatever yeah well that's what was fun
because in and I can give anything away
but there are fun surprises in the
roasts so I want us the person being
roasted I have no idea I want to love
bomb them with like crazy surprises the
mo you can see a community funny anytime
go see them live be funny right go do
that that's where comedy's supposed to
be this I wanna and people love podcasts
you guys are signing up to watch
comedians be vulnerable and serious and
emotional
which is my whole argument about like
people like comedy's male dominated
field yeah but it's a very female
profession
it is the most bitch profession there is
it's men come like going on stage
talking about their feelings and their
problems and gossiping it is the mo it's
a female job perfect job for me yes it's
a female job dominated by quote men I'm
putting that in quotes like uh I feel
bad my my wife hurt my feelings I need
to talk about it like if that was that
me like two weeks ago yeah it's very
female
right
um but uh so I want to start doing more
like surprises kind of thing like for
Bert kreischer's like you'll see
bringing out like if we were gonna love
bomb you and do a roast Dan Levy yeah
like I down the line yeah only fans
wanted to be like
like we need to capture on screen a
reaction that puts chills down your
spine like I started getting inspired
once I did the robot for my um fourth
special the reaction my robot came out
that looked exactly like me people were
like like they're reacting freaked out
my kids too yeah not your son your son
loved her and we need to talk about it
we need to get a Regis we need to like
get stat yes
um we can make people laugh we can get
standing ovations we can get pause
breaks we know how to do that right and
there's now we need to like how do we
get people to
get that Christmas morning feeling or
Hanukkah morning whatever the fuck you
and half of me celebrate
um there's no Hanukkah morning that
happens in the evening yeah so it's like
if it's you we're gonna jokes yes great
host but then I want
a flash mob and your favorite teacher
from high school comes out okay Miss K
yeah Miss K every gift begins with Miss
Kay so it's like you know what I mean so
it's like I want to like surprise people
and put in like the thoughtful time so
it's gonna be more like
undercover CIA covert Ops like I love it
surprising this person with wild shit
like I love it not not to come full
circle and be Jeremy Hots but I I timed
this wrong and I'm gonna pee in my pants
if I don't if I don't step out of this
chair right now there will be urine
everywhere
don't ride elephants but I love you I
love this podcast Dan Levy uh come on
are you still on with uh Melanie I'm
doing a few more shows with him in
January shows is that do you call them
shows they look more like parade like
inaugural parades yeah we're doing shows
in in Europe in January London Dublin
um one show in Hawaii I don't know the
wild I've never gotten an ad for a John
mulane show hat look what's happening 70
000 people going I don't there's no
banners there's no pop-up ads it's not
on my Instagram like how do people go to
this website hi how famous is this
fucking guy and then and then we do
three shows in Australia and then the
tour ends in February so it's like
Australia sunscreen yes you okay basal
cell you can't handle it okay I need
that
um yes
and uh boomerangs boomerangs and uh TV
shows forthcoming um and Dan on roast of
uh your Shirley on only fans um February
14th get ready fucking steals
show not saying I'm the best roaster but
I am did it not feel like flying did it
feel like you were flying yeah it was a
great it was very fun people were loving
it
more to come more to come love you love
you
[Music]
[Applause]